it's not an easy thing throwing that tip
when there are a couple of seven footers
as they says its first shot on the right
is good
dangerous pass always porzingis squares
fibers
percent actually now with a d7 414
porzingis porzingis three just under 28
per game as pets to grade our singers
from way downtown and it's 14 degrees
already in double figures be phenomenal
shooting look at this one straight on
with the hoop from downtown
the coach is no longer get upset with
porzingis left open again tucks it in
three for three from downtown is such a
smart player 2 on the way to porzingis
porzingis spins away
stops porzingis continues his onslaught
as he's doubled along the baseline but
to no avail and not vincible
indefensible now is
[Applause]
buzzer Santos
will not complacent coming back within
reach shixin on Millsaps that's for
years never big numbers just a good
all-around play Jack with his second
field goal and it was a different game
in the second half porzingis nice smooth
shooting over mill side and he palpable
tonight with the jumper has been KP
[Applause]
only a gas seven foot three thickener
gathered in that alley you any dozen
with such gusto an amazing grace that
gets the crowd right back kiddo at
Millsaps
[Applause]
wants to create some room turn suits
fibers kristaps porzingis
to five to shoot
for Cindy's back since pins falling away
get the Nuggets the switch and a little
serendipity as he bounces than it is but
the Knicks have a hamster
Victory's Paris black by porzingis
picked up by yogurt